every single thought we have or every
sentence we speak is an affirmation and
it's either positive or negative and
it's going out from us and it's creating
our experiences however when we talk
about doing affirmations what we're
talking about is making definite
positive statements to create something
in our life or to remove something in
our life you see if you stand there and
say I don't want this job or I don't
want this relationship or I don't want
these hips or I don't want whatever that
does not get you what you want that's
what I call fighting the negative and it
doesn't do anything but keep what you
have that you say you don't want however
if you start saying and doing
affirmations that I have a wonderful new
job then you're beginning to create what
it is you do want hey s Carmichael and I
make these videos because I need them
from me because I want to wake up every
day and watch a video that puts me in a
mindset to believe in myself more and go
off and accomplish amazing things and
attack the day and I hope that this
video does that for you as well so today
let's learn how to master the Law of
Attraction
enjoy affirmations are like planting
seeds and if you think for a moment when
you put a seed in the ground you do not
get instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree that
seed goes in the ground and it has to
germinate that's the first thing which
means it breaks open its little shell
and little Roots begin to go down and it
gets nourishment from the earth and only
then does the first little Shute come up
through the
ground now when we're doing affirmations
too often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they stomp on that
first Little Shoot they don't give it a
chance to
grow doing affirmations is like planting
a seed in the ground and watering is it
it is like repeating your affirmations
and you just keep doing them and you
keep doing them and you keep doing them
and it doesn't matter whether you see
the results or you don't see the results
and sometimes it just takes time and too
many people will do affirmations for two
or 3 days and say see doesn't
work you know
if everything happens in the perfect
time space sequence and we want to trust
that and we want to know that so if you
begin to do affirmations for yourself
and I think it's important that we do
that on a daily basis decide what you
want and begin to do positive statements
in present tense for what you want you
never want to say I will have or I'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future and remember if
you say I have a wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean mean that this is not a true
statement it means you are planting the
seed that will germinate and grow and
become the new apartment so you just
keep doing it no matter what where you
are also if you're leaving a situation
if you're in a job you don't like if
you're in a relationship you don't like
if you're in a a house you don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with
love interesting bless with love where
you are and and know that you're
releasing your current situation with
love if it's a job release it with love
to the next person who will be delighted
to have it if it's an apartment do the
same thing if it's a relationship
release that person with love to
happiness which is Meaningful to
them and that leaves you free to create
and accept happiness that is Meaningful
to you rule number two is create a
visualization with Wayne Dyer creative
visualization is what we're talking
about here you the imagery or the image
that you have of anything in your life
is really like mental Behavior it's like
going out and practicing if you go out
and practice with a basketball shooting
uh free throws over and over again
that's physical practice imagery is
mental practice it's mental behavior
when you have an image that you can
succeed at at something when you have an
image that you can do it rather than
that you can't do it when you get into
your car and you have an image that
you're going to find a parking place
rather than that there'll be no place to
park so you're not looking for no place
to park you will start acting on the
image that you have very much like you
will start acting on the practice that
you have when you're shooting baskets or
when you're hitting a forehand or or
working on your soup or anything else
that you're doing rule number three is
change the program with Bruce Lipton
when you're putting in a wish and a
desire put it in as if you already have
it I am healthy uh I am a good
relationship person uh you know I have a
great job that what's that I say it's
like I already have it and yet most
people don't have it so they'll say I
want a great job I want a great
relationship I want to be healthy and I
go make a recording of those words we
just said that I want to be healthy
today right now Tuesday we're going to
make a recording I say now come back in
one year and let's push the button on
that recording and we come back a year
later and it says I want to be healthy I
go it's a whole year and you still want
to be healthy still don't have it right
you didn't say I am healthy
all you're emphasizing I have a desire
to be healthy I want to be healthy I
have a desire to be healthy I go you can
have that desire the rest of your life
you're not going to get healthy you want
to be healthy you say I am healthy but
then you look and say yeah but in
reality I'm sick and I go no no the
function of the mind is to take the
program and turn it into reality so if I
am sick but I put a program in I am
healthy the Mind looks you know like
well wait a sec the program is I am
healthy but the body is not healthy so
what's the function of the Mind create
Health in the body it doesn't change the
program it changes the body and so the
idea is this every time we put a program
in it has to be as if you already have
it in spite of the fact you could be
dying of cancer I go I am healthy it
sounds kind of weird and I go don't
worry about it just put it on I am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality MH that's the part and so my
little caveat you brought it up I'm
emphasizing it and that was simply this
that whatever you're downloading you
have to say it as if you already have it
because if you put a future tense on it
I will I want I say if you record that
that that means you will always will you
know want to have it you know I will do
this you won't get there so I just
wanted to bring that in because if we're
making a program then you must make sure
it says as if you you already have it in
spite of the fact you don't hi I'm Bruce
lion author of the bestselling books the
biology belief spontaneous Evolution and
the honeymoon effect I'm here to thank
Evan carmichel for featuring me on his
YouTube channel and I want to let you
know that Evan is giving away links
where you can watch the First episodes
of my special Gaia series entitled in a
revolution for free evidence making this
offer to thank you for watching this
video you will find the links in the
description section below thank you rule
number four is believed with Bob Proctor
the law of
vibration do you know the
secret talked about the law of
attraction the secret was a runaway it
went viral a very bestseller it's
reported a half a billion people have
been impacted by the movie or the book
The
Secret now I was very fortunate to have
a key slot in that
movie uh it's been often said that I'm
better known in Iraq than I am in
Indiana and I think that's
true this is the primary law right
here the Law of Attraction starts with
the law of vibration and let's take a
look at where the law vibration
starts it starts right in your own mind
right in in your own
head your mind activates brain
cells and when those brain cells are
activated you're impacted you impact the
whole
universe do you know that thought waves
are cosmic waves that penetrate all time
and space you see as you get studying
this and as you start to get into it in
some depth the ideas are so vast they're
so huge and you think this is about
me see I don't think the vast majority
of us have ever been introduced to who
we really
are I think that if a person started to
show some promise and developing a a
healthy self-image they were told that
they were being conceited don't be like
that that's not the way you should be
and of course we get a lot of other bad
information in there but this law
vibration starts in our own marvelous
mind and
and I'd recommend that you start really
studying
this if you just stick with
us I what I've done I've taken some of
the most complicated material and I've
reduced it to the most simplistic form
because that was the only way I was
going to understand it and I had
marvelous teachers that helped me get
that now link said something absolutely
incredible Lincoln said many things that
are incredible but he said to believe in
the things you can see and touch is no
belief at all but to believe in the
Unseen is a Triumph and a
blessing think of
that to believe in the things you can
see and touch we've got things we can
see and
touch that's no belief at all to believe
in the Unseen is a Triumph and a
blessing do you know the biggest part of
you you'll never see the real you you'll
never see now we've got to start to we
got to start to understand this we got
to start to get it in the right slot in
our
mind we've got to realize
that there's so much to
us um that we don't we don't really get
we don't understand our educational
system is so lacking in teaching us who
we are you can study psychology but most
people that studied psychology have
never really got to know themselves I'm
talking about in depth who you really
are your relationship to the whole
scheme of thing or your relationship to
God you're talking about an infinite
power and you're created in that image
we have infinite potential locked up
within us what we want to do is learn
how to use it for good in our life and
rule number five the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is control
your brain with Joe despenza first of
all every time we have a thought we make
a chemical and and if you have uh an
unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have have a a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits that signal another part
of the brain to release peptides or
chemical Messengers that signal hormonal
centers and when we get that arousal
from the thought that we think uh those
thoughts sometimes weaken the response
weakens the physical body so turns out
that the emotions that are created from
the thoughts are the sign signaling
mechanisms to the body thoughts are the
language of the brain and feelings are
the language of the body and how we
think and how we feel uh creates our
state of being so it turns out that the
thoughts based in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words a
person wakes up in the morning and the
brain is a record of the past the first
thing they do when they wake up in the
morning is they start thinking about
their problems and those problems are
memories that are etched in the brain
that are connected to certain people
certain objects uh certain things at
certain times and places so if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny the
moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right now
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems now you feel
unhappy now you feel anxious now you
feel fear so the moment we feel those
emotions
it takes a thought and a
feeling a memory or an image and an
emotion a stimulus and a response and we
start conditioning the body emotionally
into the past now the body is so
objective that it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition so if the environment signals
the Gene and that's the truth
and the end product of an experience is
in the environment is an
emotion we're signaling the same genes
and genes make proteins and if you keep
signaling the same genes you start
downregulating the Gene and make cheaper
proteins and the body begins to break
down now that's an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is uh the
brain checks in with the body and says
yeah you're feeling pretty miserable
you're suffering and we tend to generate
more thoughts equal to the feeling that
we have and so then we get caught in
this Loop of thinking and feeling so if
we can't think greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
right and so we call that the familiar
past and then a person gets going in the
day and they start thinking oh I got to
see this person I got to go to that
meeting I hate doing this and now they
get in their routine and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through repetition The Habit is
when you've done something so many times
that the body now knows how to do it
better than the mind so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body is now dragging them into a
predictable future based on what they
did in the past and they've lost their
free will to a set of programs right so
now you have the familiar past and you
have the predictable future those are
knowns so the only place then reasonably
where the unknown exists is The Sweet
Spot of the generous present moment that
is when the body and mind are free from
those conditions so along with those
emotions that influence the same
thoughts people start becoming more
judgmental they start becoming more
impatient they start becoming more
entitled uh they start getting more
afraid more anxious more depressed
and now the body is literally being
depleted of energy because it's
believing that it's living in an
emergency situation and in emergency you
tap all of the body's resources for some
threat whether it's real or imagined and
so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool but the arousal that's
created for from those stress
hormones is a rush of energy and so then
people use the problems and the
conditions in their life to reaffirm
their conditioning or their addiction to
that emotion and in a sense they become
addicted to the life they don't even
like and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay I'm not
going to say I can't I'm not going to
judge another person I'm not going to
blame I'm not going to complain I'm not
going to make excuses I'm not going to a
victim I'm not going to talk trash about
anybody I'm just going to stop well that
works out really well for the first
couple hours and the body sing you're at
of schedule you normally at 8:00 in the
morning you're get in traffic and you're
angry then at 11:00 you check your
emails and you're really judgmental and
frustrated the body saying well you've
been doing this for the last 20 years
you're just going to stop today so now
the body which has been conditioned
emotionally to be the Mind wants to
return back to its familiar territory to
the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge come on this is a
good time to suffer it's your ex's fault
it's it's your it's the government's
fault it's uh you know it's the weather
what the news whatever it is and if we
accept believe and surrender to that
thought without analyzing it it slips by
and it begins to program the autonomic
nervous system to make those Pharmacy of
chemicals and so that's when the person
makes the same Choice does the same
thing creates the same experience just
for that familiar feeling okay I'll
complain just so I can feel suffering
then they'd rather be unhappy then step
into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process first of all is not making
the same Choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff you got to stay
conscious and not go unconscious and it
turns out that 95% of the time we're
unconscious so if you're going to stay
conscious then there's an element that
also requires a certain amount of
awareness or
energy and you got to step outside of
that unconscious state so the thoughts
that they're thinking are slipping by
their awareness unnoticed because
they're hardwired in their brain because
they've been saying I can't it's too
hard my life will never change it's
someone else's fault those thoughts have
consequen is in the body so then if a
person then becomes conscious of those
unconscious thoughts becomes aware of
how they speak and how they act and they
notice how they're feeling they're no
longer the program they're the
Consciousness outside the program and
that's the first step to change
so there there when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and your tweeting
and your instagramming and Facebooking
and whatever people do you're distracted
by that feeling but I now know that if
you take a person and you say Okay close
your eyes sit in the in the Silence of
any external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay I'm going to feed you you can check
your cell phone you can shower you can
have your coffee but when I say and so
then Here Comes The Challenge right so
and and then if you say then you're not
going to live in the famili F A Familiar
past or predictable future you're not
going to think about how long you've
been meditating what you got to do you
you Labor uh for that present
moment people think when they do this
that they're doing something wrong
because there's such discomfort that
comes with it but they're in the unknown
they're actually doing it right people
say I think I'm meditating wrong I
always say oh no no no you're doing it
right because when you notice that your
body wants to get up and check your cell
phone or have a cup of coffee and you
become aware that it's on autopilot and
wants to do that and you say uh-uh come
on over here and you return it back to
the present moment you're executing a
will now that's greater than the program
and if the person wants to just get
angry while they're sitting there
there's an arousal and they notice the
body is amping up and revving up and
they settle it back down now they're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this and it's tedious in the
beginning at first because David is
fighting Goliath but if you keep
practicing it just like training an
animal sooner or later the body
acquiesces sooner or later the body is
trained to a new mind and when that
happens there's a liberation of energy
the body goes from particle to wave from
matter to energy and there goes that
emotion literally liberated from the
body as energy so the person who has the
strong emotion to some circumstance in
their life and they're working and
lowering the volume of that emotion the
more they lower the volume of that
emotion the more they're going to take
their attention off that person and
problem and they're going to take their
power back there's going to be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self
so I think you know it's not like
thinking positively that's not the
message it's it's overcoming overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that URS and the
person starts thinking differently and
they start acting differently and they
start feeling differently they're a new
personality and they they start seeing
those synchronicities and serendipities
now Crossing that River of
change the creative process now gets
exciting because what thoughts do you
want to fire and wire in your brain what
kind of attention and
intention what is fear is fear something
that you should fear no I want you to
imagine that you're driving down the
street in your car and a light pops up
on the dashboard a light pops up um have
you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light cuz you don't like the
light of course not that would be silly
right what if the light on the dashboard
was just a signal maybe you're low on
tire air uh air pressure maybe uh you're
missing air or water in your windshield
wiper maybe the back trunk door is open
isn't the signal in your car just for
you to be aware that maybe something is
wrong or something needs attention is it
possible that if we sto thinking of fear
as the enemy fear is one of your biggest
friends why well when you understand how
did this
organism okay develop and how does it
Keep Us Alive it pays attention to
things okay in your external World
triggers from your external word that
could cause your death or destruction it
causes you to do what when there is a
potential thre threat predator or threat
at the door it lights up the fierce
signal sends cortisol epinephrine or
norepinephrine into your bloodstream so
you either know how to fight it you run
away or you freeze hoping that the
Predator will go away so when your brain
every
brain gets this signal that there is a
threat at the
door it sends a
signal in the form of a neurochemical
that you
feel now if
somebody feels this threat in their body
but they don't know how to manage the
emotion we call fear let's say there's a
fear that you have a failure and what it
might mean to your family what's what
about a fear of losing money and not
having enough to pay the rent the
mortgage or for retirement what if
there's a fear of trying something and
then it not working out and you're
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
rejected or judged oh my God if you
judge me then you're going to reinforce
my low self-esteem of myself and then oh
then who am I you understand what's
happening in the circuits I'm just
describing so when our brain has this
fear circuit activated do you think the
fear circuit causes you to go oh hey
let's take action anyway or do you think
goes high alert high alert high alert be
aware what's going on what if you fail
what if you succeed what if you succeed
and fail whenever that circuit is
triggered motivational circuit shuts
down whenever that circuit is activated
your thinking circuit shuts down all the
blood flow goes into a part of your
brain to help you do what possibly run
away protect yourself it's a protection
mechanism but here is what I want you to
remember this automatic trigger and
circuit has been evolving for millions
of years but your specific experiences
since you were born in the modeling
experiential a and the um and the
imprinting years caused you to have
beliefs about things some Empower you
some disempower let me give you an
example okay let me give you an example
when I say the word or let me give you a
different same example but just a little
different story if I say to you that I'd
like to take a big snake about 5 feet
long and let it Slither across your arm
and around your neck and it's a python
how many of you go oh wow that would be
great versus how many of you are going
oh my God let me run away G get G get it
off of me just just think of a snake
slithering on you and curling itself
around your neck how many of you are
like run versus oh my God that would be
great can you take a picture of me with
it so I can put on social
media so is it really the snake that is
the threat or is it your Concept in your
brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center and for others the fear Center
same stake stain stimuli there isn't
even a snake here I just add you think
about it right and it triggered that
fear circuit for some reward circuit for
others so it's never about the thing so
when we have fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed judged uh fear of
disappointing ourselves fear of failing
fear of succeeding there's 50 different
types of fears we automatically
trigger the circuit that does what stops
our action taking just give yourself
permission to to want the things that
you want and unless you believe that
you're worthy unless that you practice
love you're never going to think that
you deserve the things that you want
right so tell the
story okay so I'm probably going
toally I I'll shorten it I'll shorten it
so the the bottom line is that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience that you may be able to
relate to and that is I walked in and I
immediately saw this painting hanging on
the wall and it was about the size of a
door only horizontal and it was a
Vermont landscape and I was drawn into
it immediately like I was no longer in
that restaurant I was standing in that
field I could feel that breeze I'd never
ever had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean my yeah my
sense was that this is very atypical for
you very so
I kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then I leaned
back I'm suddenly kind of back in the
moment I'm like I'm going to own this
painting someday it just that was what
was right there and I looked at the
price and it said like $3,000 I'm like
not today and I went back and I sat down
and that was it but the painting never
left my mind you see there's something
called the zenar effect I I always say
it wrong but it's like there's a
checklist in your brain that when you
have a moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah there's like a notch yes
a notch happens and now your brain as
part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember so uh bottom
line is uh I always thought about that
painting years go by whenever somebody
would say Vermont I'd think of the
painting I don't know why I can't
explain it never wanted a painting
before was not an art student it's going
to law school it's like you're out
collecting art no no no and so I you
know fast forward the story 10 years and
my uh H Chris and I are are engaged and
we're going to go up to Vermont to see
the leaves and immediately I'm like we
got to go to Simon Pierce I got to show
you the painting so we pull up to the
mill and we walk in and right in front
there is Boom a painting by the same
artist Gail Shephard and I'm like oh my
God it's here and we race all around the
place and it's gone and the funny thing
was and this is the way your brain works
Chris was more disappointed than I was I
literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we were
still here after 10 years I'm going to
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's going to happen
Chris I'm G to be able to buy this like
40 years from now it's going to be
hanging in the corporate Lobby of some
building and I'm G to have to track down
the owner and pay like quadruple the
money they pay but I'm goingon to own
this Mission yes so a couple years pass
and um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says Chris gets a
couple people
to give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had I had
what 500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the
time with our first kid I should have
bought a crib or stools but for whatever
reason the zigen arch effecta takes over
and I'm like the painting so I call the
mill and I get this guy on the phone I'm
like uh you know I want to buy a kale
Shepard piece and I said could you send
me Polaroids and he's like sure and I
tell him the budget and he goes I'll
I'll send you Polaroids of some of her
smaller things mhm and she's like
blowing up in the meantime right yeah
she's a very very successful Vermont
landscape artist and so
I I I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting and I describe
the painting I had seen over 10 years
ago and he said well that was way before
my time but I bet Gail will know and I'm
like Gail you know Gail he's like of
course I know Gail she like lives in in
down the road here's her her number so
for 2 days I paced around the apartment
with 500 bucks in my pocket driving
Chris crazy cuz I felt like what am I
going to say to her and I must be a
weirdo I've been stalking this lady I've
been thinking about her for 10 years I
can't afford a painting you know what
who am I to buy a painting like what the
hell so finally Chris is like would you
call her or I'm going to call her you're
driving me crazy so I call her and I
start talking a mile a minute and she
was
amazing and then um I said by the way
there was this one painting and I go and
I explain this painting there's a stand
of popler trees down the center and a
big mountainscape behind it and this
beautiful blue Vermont sky and geese
flying in formation overhead and I could
hear her thinking on the other end of
the line and she said you know Mel I've
done so many large
scale uh paintings over the years I'd
hate to mistake the one you're talking
about but I'll tell you what what if my
husband and I meet you and Chris at the
Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll walk all
around and have lunch and I'll tell you
the stories behind every painting and if
you don't see what you like there I'll
take you back to my studio which is a
couple miles down the river and you can
look at everything I'm working on and if
you don't see anything you like there
then you can go through all my slides
and see if you can find that painting
that you saw 10 years ago and I said
deal so a month passes we go up to the
mill I walk in we meet each other she's
amazing she's like twice our age just
incredibly cool lady she's walking
around as we're walking around looking
at these paintings Rich I've got I'm
like eight months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I
have I can't afford this like I don't I
don't have this kind of
money and I'm getting like more and more
into that impostor syndrome what am I
doing mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed
I'm meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time cuz she thinks she's is going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down and she goes now that you're
sitting down I have something to tell
you
um she said there's only been two times
in my career as an artist that I've done
two studies of the same
piece and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11
years I start sobbing everybody's like
totally emotional her husband's like you
should have seen her when you when she
was on the phone with you was like she
saw a ghost so we get in the car and we
drive to the mill and when we walk in
there in the center of this massive kind
of Barn Studio space is an easel with a
painting taped up with painters tape on
it and it was the sister to my painting
there were slight differences not as
much movement in the grass but it
was one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was standing before that
painting in 199
saying it would be mine and there I was
11 years
later standing in front of it and then I
realized oh my God I can't afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing and he kind of leans over and goes
hey Gail how much for the big one and
she said um Mel can have it for5 100
bucks cuzz clearly when I was making it
11 years ago I was making it for
her
yeah and so it hangs in my kitchen it's
on the back of the book um this is the
galy though right so wait is it in the
is it in I think so yeah yeah and um
it's a reminder every day that your mind
is designed to help you get what you
want I never stopped believing that I
could make it happen and when you tell
your mind what's important to you there
is extraordinary
science that proves that your mind has a
live and everchanging filter a live
Network that changes how it views the
world What it lets in what it blocks out
and if you program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want the biggest message I want
to get across when it comes to the law
of attraction is that it requires effort
it requires some type of action that's
why in the word attraction you see
action in the word you don't just get to
write down something on a piece of paper
or have a vision board or you know map
something out or cut out photos and and
look at it in front of you every single
day or write down things on a piece of
paper and think hard about it for a few
minutes and then expect everything in
your life to change and to be this
magnet of opportunities have everyone
that you want in your life attracted to
you money good health opportunities with
your career that's not going to happen
overnight like that and I wish it did
but it's not that easy so there are some
beliefs and actions that we need to take
place in order for it to work and that's
what we're going to do by diving into
today so the first thing you want to
think about is switching from negativity
to positivity so many people get caught
up in focusing on what they don't want
to happen in their future and I want to
talk about this a little bit towards the
end of this video on how to focus on
some of the negative things that could
happen but really focusing on the
positive for the main part of your life
we'll talk about that towards the end
because this is an important distinction
but they start living almost in constant
fear of what could go wrong and what
won't work out and when we come from
this place of well I don't know if I put
myself out there you know it's not going
to work out and then I'm going to get
made fun of and then people I'm going to
be embarrassed and I'm going to be
stressed and no one's going to love me
and then we go in this rabbit hole and
this kind of cycle of fear and anxiety
and that is not how you attract good
things in your life you can't start from
your way of being of negativity and fear
and expect to attract beautiful things
in your life so we we need to eliminate
the negative selft talk and an
environment that's easy to get stuck in
sometimes can be the negative selft talk
and there's so much negativity in the
world and if you don't actively work to
shift your focus to shift your thoughts
and your mind that negativity will
consume you and that's where the Law of
Attraction comes in now for me it's
about focusing Less on what I don't want
to happen in the future and actually
focus on what I do want and again I
think a lot of people focus on what they
don't want too much and you start to
attract the things you're thinking about
I don't want this I don't want that
those things start to come you start to
see them it's like the ex old example if
someone says you know don't think of a
pink elephant you start to see it and
you start to imagine it if you say well
I don't want to be poor you start to
feel it and you start to imagine it and
you start to have anxiety around it so
you want to really think about the
positive things in your life you want to
think about what do I want to attract
who do I want to become what do I want
to overcome so for example if you're
becoming a negative person you're more
likely to attract more negative people
rather than positive ones because
positive people won't want to be around
you you know negativity keeps company
and so does positivity when you start to
see other positive people that are like
you you say I want to hang out with
those people those people are going to
continue to lift me up I can lift them
up it's a good cycle but the negative
stuff you start to attract when you talk
about gossip and you talk about bad news
and you talk about comparison and
judgment and anxiety and stress that
feeds in a community of other people
that speak in the same language so you
want to shift your language and start
thinking more positively and if you feel
like you aren't deserving of a loving
relationship a loving partner you're
most likely going to attract the wrong
type of people in your life and if
you're focusing on how much money you
don't have in your life right now or how
your business could fail you're not
going to be able to focus your energy on
the right clients or the products that
will take your business to the next
level or the skills you need to develop
to help you grow now your thoughts
dictate your actions and where your
energy goes so you want to be thinking
about what can I do to replace these
negative thoughts the anxiousness or the
fear how can I replace it so my energy
can go in a more positive direction and
again where you put your energy into is
what you
attract so if you're thinking negative
thoughts all day long you'll probably to
attract that if you're thinking
gratitude and positive thoughts you'll
start to see that show up differently so
how can we put the Law of Attraction
into practice now let's go back to our
examples and apply a new way of thinking
if you are caught in thinking negatively
about the world and about yourself this
is so important what would change inside
of you if you looked around and you
wrote down five things that you're
grateful for about the world now this
for me is part of the secret to the Law
of Attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that I
should not have attracted because I
didn't have the skills because I didn't
have the tools because I didn't have the
education because I didn't have the
money because I didn't have the
resources so many things that I
shouldn't have attracted but because I
had the foundation of
gratitude passion Joy curiosity those
things started to come to me and they
can come to you as well if you come from
that place of gratitude as your
foundation so you want to think about
what are these things that are important
to me in my life you know it can be
simple things it could be like this cup
of coffee that I have right now it can
be that I have a roof over my head that
I've got quality friends that I'm
healthy you know that I'm walking in
nature today it doesn't have to be some
grandiose thing that's happened to you
to be grateful for I'm so grateful for
these little present moments with people
that I care about to spend an hour on
the beach to go for a walk with a friend
to have a good conversation with someone
and talk about something that I'm going
through for me that's just as meaningful
the moments in between the big moments
are just as meaningful so write down
these things or think about these things
this is something I embed in my daily
life when I wake up I think about what
I'm grateful for when I go to sleep I I
think about and reflect on the things
I'm grateful for from that day and it's
just my way of being for as much as I
can now I'm not perfect I make mistakes
and there's sometimes I'm negative but
it's something that I try to really
focus on as much as possible so instead
of saying that you're not enough
that you don't deserve success what if
you looked in the mirror on a daily
basis I dare you to look in the mirror
on a daily basis and say I am enough and
I do deserve the results that I want to
create in my life because I show up
because I'm consistent because I work
hard because I care about my work if you
looked in the mirror and you did this
consistently for 30 days and you
actually use the word action in
attraction and you put it into practice
on a daily basis towards that growth I'd
be amazed to see what you attract and
what you manifest in your life or if you
felt like you weren't deserving of a
loving partner and just kept focusing on
the wrong people what if you said you
know what I am deserving of a loving
partner because I care deeply about
those around me and I'm worthy of
feeling deeply cared about myself and
what if you started to change your
thoughts and behaviors around yourself
and say I'm not going to keep doing the
things that I've always done I'm going
to start showing up differently and love
myself not needing someone else to love
me who maybe isn't in the right mindset
and start distancing yourself from those
typical patterns that you've had in the
past and love yourself first and see
what you attract from that loving
grateful place with yourself or if you
are in a tough Financial spot maybe
you're struggling financially and you've
been trying to start a business or a
side hustle I've been there I know what
this feels like it's not fun for a long
time I was living on my sister's couch
and I didn't have much money it was
really stressful I remember this feeling
of being stuck feeling like I was never
going to make any money and when I was
focusing on that feeling of I'm never
going to make this money I feel stuck I
feel trapped when's this going to happen
feeling this anxiousness this stress
around it it was really impossible for
me to think of creative ideas it was
impossible for me to take action because
I was living in the stress as opposed to
the gratitude for what I was having in
that moment I should have been focusing
on you know what my sister is allowing
me to stay here for free so I have some
time to learn a new skill I made $100
this day I should be grateful for that
not a focusing on what I'm lacking or
what I don't have but what I am creating
on a daily basis and I started to ask
different questions around this time
like how can I be of service to other
people how can I add as much value to
someone else or what are my top skill
sets that I can use to my advantage that
no one else has like what do I have I
started writing a list of all these
different skills that I had even when I
didn't think I had many skills I still
wrote down a list of the qualities I
have of the skills from the past that
maybe I could apply to right now and
when I began asking those types of
questions I started attracting the
people who needed my skill sets and
services and I finally started to make
more money than ever before because I
was thinking about serving others I was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
I'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and I'll never make anything from
this situation I started focusing on how
can I add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can I serve them how
can I create for them how can I connect
someone to them that could help them
what can I do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
I think as Zig Ziggler said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what I started focusing on not
what I'm lacking but how can I give and
how can I add value to other people when
you focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect one
person helping another person how it
comes back around to
you because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for some incredible Wayne Dy
affirmations check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you can't give away what you don't
have people who are not good at giving
away love can't give away love because
they don't have it to give away